[Music]
insects are true masters of flight small
lightweight and highly maneuverable
scientists have been taking inspiration
from our six legged friends to try and
create flying robots of the same size
but it's proven difficult because when
you get down to the insects scale it's
hard to generate enough thrust to carry
your own power source but there's a new
robot in town that's creating a bit of a
buzz
this is Robo be x-wing it's got a
wingspan of just three and a half
centimeters and it's about a quarter of
the weight of a paperclip at this scale
batteries are just too heavy to be
carried on board so the researchers used
ultra lightweight solar cells these
generate power and send it to a control
board that operates a pair of
piezoelectric actuators clever materials
that work a bit like a muscle and
contract when a voltage passes across
them by sticking two actuators together
they Bend back and forth to flap the
bots wings
these seminal flights lasted for less
than a second and required more than
twice the energy contained in sunlight
but they represent an important
milestone for flight at this scale and
even supersede the thrust efficiency of
living insects they're certainly still
room for improvement the aerodynamics of
the wings are not as efficient as a real
insects and of course the controls that
insects pack into their tiny compact
brains are a long way off for robobee
x-wing but this model produced more
thrust than it needed and in the future
that could be used to carry controls
sensors maybe even some sort of battery
the hope is that these miniature robotic
insects will one day be able to achieve
continuous outdoor flight and help with
environmental and disaster monitoring
perhaps even operating in a swarm
you
[Music]